I don't feel I have a very high heavy
burden since I have Jack and con on my
side,
but it's also a great pleasure to appear
with such worthy adversaries if I can.
If I can,
I use that term in the age of Obama.
Maybe partners,
I should say.
I very much hope the president changes
his,
his foreign policy,
but for now I'm afraid it's a failure.
How can you talk about the unsafe?
Well,
now,
wow.
If God forbid something had happened to
John Mccain,
we'd have President Pailin.
Boy,
we'd all sleep safely and our bands
wouldn't it.
The greatest gift to the animism.
Erica was the eight.
Yeah.
Fiasco.
A masterpiece of ineptitude,
calamity,
and arrogance.
That was the administration of George W
Bush
standing on a stage here when encourages
theatrical performances.
We just got one and I'm the more
serious.
Got It.
All right.
I'm going to.
I'm a military guy.
I'm pretty serious.
I'm going to deal with facts and less
with the metrics.
My feeling,
my belief is that President Obama is
early Chinese.
I vote no against a reasonably shun it.
I think that Barack Obama is not a gift
to our enemies,
but is a two hour the and the most
efficient of it,
most efficient for poisons,
which are the Chinese boy zones.
I think Barack Obama,
among his many gifts,
has the intellectual and moral force to
look at this new map.
Clearly it is one in which we cannot
isolate strategic problems from legal
problems.
I just like to address my former tutor,
Simon Schama.
I often found the,
his tour de force in the tutorial is
rather than using as I did today,
my dear my dear former professor,
um,
failed to address the motion here.
This motion is about Obama's foreign
policy,
not how much we detest George Bush or
share a painter
thing about thinking about student calm.
Was He always had,
you know,
he was saying,
I'm going to give you the facts,
which actually meant I haven't actually
read the assignment.
No.
Actually,
when I ever get the facts right,
Bush may have been heavy handed and the
way he spoke for democracy,
but at least he spoke to democracy.
He has the same enemies as the previous
administrations,
but that he deals with these enemies in
a way more wise and we mall.
I said poison,
let's say with more boys than his
predecessor was.
Thank you.
You.